>> All right, so turns out it, it matters how we
select training examples when when a learner is needing to learn.
So let's at least articulate some various ways that training examples
could be selected. And then for each one we might end
up with a different answer as to how much training data
is going to be needed, if the training examples are selected in
that particular way. So, so what do you think, Charles? Are
there, there any ways you can think of for selecting training examples?
>> Well, so, I, I, I so here's how
I think about it. So, you keep using the word
learner, and when there's a learner there's often a
teacher. So, I'm trying to think about this in the
different ways that learners and teachers can interact. So,
I'm going to try to think about my, my experience as
a professor. So, there are a couple. Here's one,
one is: sometimes the learner asks questions of the teacher.
>> I see,
so in this case, the learner would be
selecting the training examples. The learner would say,
I, you know, here's, here's an input x, would you please tell me c of x?
>> Right, that's exactly what I mean, right,
right. Then there's another case. So the learner
asks questions of the teacher. But sometimes the
teacher just goes ahead and gives x, c(x) pairs.
>> And let's say it's, it actually is trying to help the learner.
>> Sure.
>> So
it's a, friendly teacher.
>> Okay, I've had some of those.
>> Good, all right so, the, it could be
the, the learner asking to try to get data.
It could be the teacher asking to try to
lead the learner to something good. And, anything else?
>> Well, so, I like this, this way of thinking about it. Because
it sort of makes sense in my world as a professor, but it doesn't actually
sound like either of things is what we've been looking at so far. What
I think we've been looking at so far is that somehow the Xs and
the CXs, the training examples, just come out of nowhere.
They come from some underlying distribution. It's just nature. It's just
coming at us from some process that we don't know what
that process is. Yeah, I like that. So in some sense
there's three individuals that could be asking for examples. There's
the teacher, there's the learner, and there's, like, the world around
them. And, and, the things could come from any of those.
I guess another possibility would be that questions are asked specifically
in an evil way. All right, so all
of these different kinds of distributions or, or
ways of selecting training examples are actually going
to come into play in the stuff that
we're talking about. Let's let's use the first
couple to get a sense of why these
things might be different from each other. So
let's go back to this notion of 20 questions.
>> Okay.